you guys met in clown you met his clown
yes see that's not helping my thought on
clowns everyone's like did we hear that
right they made us clowns yeah you met
as clowns
lady clowns well we went to nyu and our
parents paid
50 grand a year for us to do clown work
that's got to feel good not to them it
didn't feel great to them yeah you feel
great and i i will correct you on one
point you know clowns don't really have
or the type of clown work we did you
don't really have a gender so you said
lady clowns and i just would prefer
clown
so i prefer more gender-neutral cuts i
understand
just to be clear as if clowns weren't
scary enough sure now they're just
neutral they're deep
yeah genitalia just a smooth white base
can i say on behalf of all of the clown
consuming community
in clown class basically you learn that
you have a clown persona that is you
distilled to like one emotion
and i found out that my clown was just
angry
and june's was dumb
dumbest gross
angry that's correct clown work is
really like about just eat no
not i can't lose this happening not
really putting anything on
um you know when we would be side
coached by our our clown professor
and
sorry was he in clown mission
genderless they're genderless
was this genderless nightmare in clown
makeup
i gotta stop you there i gotta stop you
there you guys are thinking circus
clowns and i can understand why you
would but i beg you to know this was a
little more of a sophisticated clown
like a marcel marceau yeah so just
a simple red nose would do for us like
patch adam's telling a child they have
leukemia
we take great offense to them yeah and
the clown that i was for four weeks i
take yeah we did this for four weeks by
the way we're not you're not a
professional clown although are we
that's the learnable moment here we're
like aren't we all clowns
which camera clowns clowns clowns
clowns clowns
well we were trying to think what you
would be if you were and you are a clown
yes
and if you distilled to one essence and
we had two different thoughts
yeah i thought a very sweet oh sweet
clown the sweet clown and i thought a
very sexual clown
but again
and she corrected clowns also don't have
a sexual orientation clown police
he pulls you over and puts you in the
back seat with 50 other clowns